I'm first off I want to thank everyone
for coming out today I appreciate the
audience here and I'm sure Todd Tucker
here appreciates it as well I do want to
ask well as many of you can see we are
being filmed today c-span is here so I
do want to ask if you have a cell phone
or pager on you you please go ahead and
turn that off just to let those of you
know who may not know every wednesday at
noon we offer some kind of free program
here in at the Historical Society and
once a month we do highlight an author
and his book or her book usually
something that focuses on Indiana
history and today is no exception today
Todd Tucker will be discussing his book
Notre Dame vs the clan how the Fighting
Irish defeated the Ku Klux Klan Todd is
from Valparaiso Indiana he graduated
from Notre Dame with a degree in history
after graduation he served in the Navy
he has also written some other books
Notre Dame game day and magazine
articles for inside sports and historic
traveler Todd's going to speak for about
30 or 40 minutes and then we're going to
open things up to you guys to ask some
questions there is a microphone set up
in the middle of the room here if you
could go to that microphone and ask a
question that would be great if anyone
is a little intimidated by that it's
okay raise your hand ask the question
Todd will repeat it for the cameras and
we'll certainly discuss any questions
that you have so if you would please
help me welcome Todd Tucker
hi thanks a lot for having me it's great
to be here I'm a member of the Indian
Historical Society and one of the images
on the cover is from your archive so
it's great to be here I'm going to the
book is about two days of rice that took
place in 1924 between the students of
the University of Notre Dame and the Ku
Klux Klan that what the events that led
up to the riots and the aftermath and
I'm going to start with just a brief
reading describing that first the early
Saturday morning May seventeenth the
first day of the riots on Saturday May
17 19 24 Notre Dame's off-campus
students awoke to the strange sight of
men and white robes directing traffic
from every South Bend street corner the
students had been anticipating the rally
for weeks nonetheless it was shocking to
see the men in the famous robes and
hoods standing in the streets of South
Bend in broad daylight American flags on
their cars Maltese crosses on their
chests as their brethren poured in from
the hinterlands the Klansmen on the
streets courteously directed them to the
park where they were to gather still
rubbing their eyes the Notre Dame n
drifted out of their apartments and
boardinghouses outside they overheard
conversations confirming that the Klan
was planning to parade through town
permit or no the Notre Dame men curious
and somewhat angry watched his clansmen
filled the streets of the city they
wondered how the first beautiful day of
the year would end the balmy weather
begged for boisterous outdoor activity
if the Klan hadn't been in town the
young men of Notre Dame might have spent
the day tossing footballs across the
quad walls resisted the Fairweather's
call to optimism and a departure from
his practice public obliviousness to the
clan he issued a statement imploring his
young charges to stay on campus the
tight single space bulletin was posted
around campus and in every residence
hall early on saturday morning it read
it has been rumored that the Ku Klux
Klan is to hold some sort of gathering
in the vicinity of South Bend this
evening there is also a rumor to the
effect that there may be a parade of the
clan in South Bend Notre Dame is
interested in the proposed meeting of
the clan but not to the extent of
wishing to interfere with whatever plans
may have been made for a demonstration
similar attempts of the clan to flaunted
strength of resulted in riotous
situations sometimes in the
of life however aggravating the
appearance of the clan maybe remember
that lawlessness baguettes lawlessness
youngblood and thoughtlessness may
consider it a duty to show what a real
American thinks of the clan there's only
one duty that presents itself to Notre
Dame men under the circumstances and
that is to ignore whatever demonstration
may take place today this suggestion
should be taken in all seriousness it is
my wish that the clan be ignored as they
deserve to be ignored and that the
students have would any occasion of
coming into contact with our clan
brethren during their visit to South
Bend let the South Bend authorities take
care of the situation the place for
Notre Dame men this afternoon and
tonight is on the Notre Dame campus any
injury or even a more serious mishap to
a single Notre Dame man would be too
great a price to pay for a protest which
in the nature of things is unnecessary
and highly undesirable to the
authorities of both the University and
South Bend he signed the bullet and
father Matthew Walsh CSC president it
was the kind of notice that a young
Matthew Walsh would have obeyed without
question it was a logical clear order
from a legitimate authority to the
majority of the students though the
document made the situation in town even
more irresistible a parade without a
permit right of situations loss of life
Walsh was a war hero yet even he seemed
to think that something spectacular was
going to occur in South Bend how could
they not at least go into town to check
things out many of Notre Dame's Catholic
students had growing up hearing lies
about their faith and challenges to
their patriotism now the greatest
expression of anti-catholicism the clan
was preparing to march right by their
University unlike Walsh the students of
Notre Dame were not inclined to ignore
the clan meanwhile two miles south of
Notre Dame the Klansmen were converging
the clans stood for an older America an
America that would soon be gone if not
defended in Indiana the Klan had
maintained a holding action against what
it perceived to be an onslaught of
foreigners in its country and it was on
the verge of creating a clan ruled
Society the Klan would celebrate that
achievement in South Bend by the time
Walsh issued his bullet on saturday
morning at the antagonist in this battle
were already running toward each other
at full speed a collision in downtown
South Bend was unavoidable
alright I'm going to get into the slides
now and talk about what led to that
Saturday and what happened after I'm a
lot of time for questions after I'll
leave a lot of time for that because
it's probably more fun for all of us the
Notre Dame riot represented a collision
to uniquely American institutions the
University of Notre Dame and the Ku Klux
Klan both those groups were growing
rapidly in the first half of the 20s and
it was some of the same historic
movement to work and was propelling the
growth of both groups mainly the huge
influx of Catholic immigrants into this
country the bright side of that was
these immigrants were striving for the
middle class and wanted to send their
kids to a catholic islands like Notre
Dame the dark side of that was the
anxiety that a lot of America felt about
these changes and that dark side
manifested itself in the Ku Klux Klan
the two institutions at that time both
had very charismatic very overachieving
young leaders in Matthew father Matthew
Walsh at Notre Dame and DC Stephenson to
the clan and i'll talk more about them
as we go on just briefly I want to talk
about some of the things that were going
on in 1924 America part of the clan
sales pitch 22 Hoosiers and everybody
else was that they were alive at a time
of great social upheaval and then
something like the Klan was needed to
maintain the things that they held dear
in America so some of the things that
were going on at that time Stalin came
to power j edgar Hoover on the verge of
the Red Scare became head of the Bureau
investigation which would become the FBI
Leopold and Loeb were convicted of their
thrill kill in Chicago average income
prohibition was about halfway through
its run had been an infection 1919 I
prohibition when it was passed
interestingly was a part of the part of
the pitch for prohibition was that it
was an anti-immigrant measure was going
to be used to keep the hard-drinking
Catholic immigrants in line
women have only been allowed to vote
just barely won election cycle in 1924
and the Scopes trial was a year later
and Sacco and Vanzetti with the
anarchists were executed in 1927 so I
might wait on that slide is just that
the part of the clans pitch was that
things in America we're not going well
you can see some of the things that
might have made that pitch effective one
of the questions I get asked a lot is
why this episode of the clan virtually
taking over Indiana at every level is so
little known i suspect in this room and
the indiana sorrel society it's more
well-known than it is in a lot of places
but one of the reasons i think that is
is because the whole thing happened so
quickly the rise and fall of the clan
happened so fast and i just want to show
that quickly here early in 1920 DC
Stephenson the clan found each other in
Evansville Indiana prior to nineteen
twenty there was no clan in Indiana by
1923 Stevenson had built the clan up to
the point where he was able to have two
hundred thousand people at a single
rally in kokomo indiana and that's where
he was a coordinated grand dragon in
1924 an avowed Klansmen and good friend
of Stephenson said Jackson was elected
governor in March 1925 Stephenson
kidnapped and raped modular holds or a
young state employee that he had met at
ed Jackson's inauguration she died in
April Stevens who was convicted of her
murder in 1925 in the clan rapidly
collapsed so you can see the whole thing
happened relatively quickly inside of
about five years now i want to just
super impose on some of the things that
were going on a notre dame at the same
time december fifteenth nineteen twenty
George get converted on his deathbed to
Catholicism odd the better no one part
of that story is he gave the famous win
one for the Gipper deathbed speech or
maybe he didn't depending on whose whose
version of adventures relief and he was
also another names first all-american
that year and the growth of the great
Notre Dame football enterprise was well
underway rocky had been coached for two
years at that point
in May seventeenth through the 19th
another name ride happened and in the
following football season after perhaps
the most anti-catholic year in American
history Notre Dame when its first
national championship with the four
horsemen at the Rose Bowl so you seed
that five years between 1920 and 1925
was a pivotal period of time for both
groups the Ku Klux Klan in Notre Dame
and when I started writing this book I
wanted to show how it was possible that
this happened that the Klan took over a
state and had this ride and what I by
the time I finished the book I wanted to
show how was really inevitable that this
confrontation had to happen at some
point I mentioned earlier that both
groups had charismatic young leaders
this is father Matthew all she was
president of Notre Dame he was 32 years
old in 1924 which is young for a
president of the University he had it
was a decorated World War one veteran he
then it's a Second Battle of the Marne
in France and he'd been president for
only two years DC Stephenson the Grand
Dragon was 33 years old so about the
same age he was also a role or one
veteran and he had been grand dragon for
one year since the kokomo rally I just
in the book I go into depth on this and
I just want to briefly touch on the
history of Notre Dame because it is I
think it does speak to the Catholic
experience in America for a school that
became famously associated with the
Irish it was founded by a French priest
father Edward sword and one of the
interesting things I found as i as i
read this was that the Ku Klux Klan
weren't the only people that held
stereotypes against the Irish I want to
read what father Soren said about this
influx of Irish immigrants to the
country in his chronicles this is father
ever storing the founder of the
University he said the Irish are by
nature full of faith respect religious
inclinations and are sensible and
devoted but a great defect often
paralyzes in them all their other good
qualities to lack of stability so that's
what a French priests had to say about
his Irish comrades-in-arms there he
founded to the University 1842 he'd come
to Indiana to be a missionary priest in
Vincennes Indiana and almost immediately
began butting heads with the bishop and
the bishop more or less exiled on
to an even more remote part of Indiana
around South Bend hoping that he would
be returned you know sufficiently
humbled but somehow father Soren managed
to found this great Catholic University
when he was up there he lives into the
1880s and ruled the school with more or
less and I heard says the whole time he
was alive one of the great events late
and father saurons presidency or his
life was the Great Fire of Notre Dame in
eighteen seventy nine it was a watershed
moment for the university the school had
been in existence for about 30 years the
fire destroyed almost every building on
campus and father sworn an old man it's
thought most of his life's work was
laying at his feet and ashes and as he
walked amongst the still smoldering
embers he said that if it was all gone
he would not give up and then at the
mass he delivered that day said that the
fire was his fault because he had not
dreamed big enough for Notre Dame and
that's why God had let this happen
because he was supposed to build
something even bigger and the building
that rose up was the golden dome which
is still really the emblem of the
University inside the golden dome they
painted a series of murals and the
subject they chose for the murals was
Columbus which is significant because it
was intended to show the place that
Americans have in the American story
brief history of the clan the Klan of
the 1920s that rided with the Notre Dame
students was really the second
historical incarnation of the clan the
claim that kind of has three separate
errors that are more or less
historically independent the first one
came out of the South out of
reconstruction after the Civil War it
was not founded by Nathan Bedford
Forrest as you often hear but he was the
first Grand Wizard Shelby Foote the
great Civil War historian once said that
the Civil War only produced two
authentic geniuses and they were Abraham
Lincoln and Nathan Bedford Forrest so he
was a great military genius and he
willingly took over the clan but within
two years of him taking over the clan
was so out of control and so violent
that this man who had been an almost
continuous combat for five years of the
Civil War the site is that the group had
become too violent for him and he issued
his own one and only general order his
Grand Wizard and disbanded the clan it
lived on
for a little bit after but it more or
less went dormant after that general
order the second incarnation of the clan
the clan that concerns us with the Notre
Dame riot came to life in the 20th
century as a result of a motion picture
it was DW Griffith's masterpiece Birth
of a Nation the movie came out in 1915
and enterprising defrocked Methodist
minister named William Simmons in
Atlanta decided that he was going to
found a fraternal organization and he
was going to make lots of money selling
memberships and he decided that the most
effective marketing tool would be this
the most successful motion picture ever
made at that point so he was going to
refound the Ku Klux Klan and that's what
he did but Simmons found out like
Forrest had before him that the Klan has
a tendency to grow beyond the control of
its leaders there's another scene from
birth the nation the battle scene just a
brief history of Matthew Walsh the
president a Notre Dame at the time of
the rides this is a picture of him right
there at the age of 15 that's the year
he left his Catholic school in Chicago
and join the seminary at Notre Dame and
he would never leave this is he ended up
getting a PhD this is for the first year
book in which he appears his back when
this seminar left-hand corner I printed
this photograph in the book because I
thought it was interesting that how
young he looks first of all and secondly
he's the only PhD on the page so it
shows you something about a Notre Dame
it but no training faculty at the time
in the 1911 at the age of 29 Walsh was
asked to become vice president and he
did at 29 years old when World War one
broke out in 1918 Notre Dame just as it
had in the Civil War moves conspicuously
and quickly to support the war effort
once again in this ongoing effort to
show that Catholics put in fact the good
patriotic Americans and father walls the
vice president University left his job
and became a chaplain and that's him a
chaplain school and he did he served
with distinction in France he was gassed
at the Second Battle of the Marne and he
ended up winning the Distinguished
Service Cross for his service
there's another picture I woloson
newsroom when walls returned to Notre
Dame he found much to his surprise that
the the kind of perennial shaky finances
of the school were beginning to be
bolstered by football of all things
which almost nobody in the
administration could understand but they
accepted it Rockne Knute Rockne has been
head coach since 1918 the George Gipp
phenomenon happened in nineteen twenty
and Notre Dame was on the verge of
becoming a nationally known institution
no during football is on the verge the
stadium you see there it looks like that
kind of a high school field by today's
standard that is in fact where Rockne
played all his games at that point skal
kar da field and it was grossly under
sized for Notre Dame and rockin was one
of the many things that he continuously
agitated for was a new stadium I think I
connects to the shadow Rockne there's
this is rotten here practicing in front
of freshman Hall a building that no
longer exists Rockne for his entire
tenure at Notre Dame was Notre Dame's
highest paid employee he was very
difficult to work with and had strained
relations with all the presidents
including Matthew Walsh he was
continuously threatening to lead the
University and at one point he even
signed a contract with Columbia when he
was still under contract with Notre Dame
so he was a difficult to work with and
one of the main things that irked him
was that he was making all this money
for the University and they wouldn't
build him a stadium that sounds pretty
pretty mother there's a picture of new
rocky and babe ruth to the best-known
sporting figures of the day but like i
said the clan and stevenson found each
other in evansville in 1920 the clannad
sent one of its recruiter Stan Deanna
they decided they wanted to expand into
the north not not historically
successful for the clan but they wanted
to try it anyway so they sent over a guy
named Joe Huffington to Evansville
Indiana which seventh bill is about the
southernmost point in the edge but you
all know and this joe huffington started
asking around he said who's who's the
best salesman in evansville and the name
he kept getting back with this guy DC
Stephenson who had become wealthy
several times over in a string of sales
jobs and he was hands-down known as the
the best salesman and Adams them so
Huffington approached him and said how'd
you like to sell memberships in the Ku
Klux Klan and Stevenson when he heard
that he would get four dollars on a very
ten-dollar membership fee signed up so
Stephenson joined the Klan not as an
ideological Klansmen but to make money
that's not to say he wasn't a racist or
a bigot didn't agree with all that I
think he probably was but he his concern
is driving concern throughout all this
was to build his bank balance and his uh
his political power Stevenson's that
technique for a recruiting Klansmen
there were a lot of them but one of his
mainland's was these massive all day
free rallies it was a technique he
learned from the socialist in Oklahoma
who he worked for briefly and he would
have these massive rallies all day
rallies with free food and music and
patriotic speeches and he would recruit
Hoosiers and drove at these meetings the
one in kokomo was his biggest he had one
in Valparaiso and by 1924 there's
Hartford City Indiana this picture is a
clan funeral I wanted to make the point
a clan like a lot of fraternal gers the
day wanted to insinuate itself in a kind
of all ceremonies in public and private
life there's the Muncie clan in 1923
well by 1924 schema sins Stevenson's
clan in Indiana had been on kind of a
northern march from Evansville and by
1924 South Bend Indiana the second
biggest city in Indiana was a logical
choice for the next all day rally so
Stevenson scheduled the rally and the
administration Notre Dame and the
leadership of the clan started looking
at each other nervously so what happened
was amazed 17 that part of the book i
read from you was the learning students
woke up and saw these clans been pouring
into 10 their first response was just
curiosity they came into town they
wanted to see what was going on and that
was quickly followed by a phase where
they started just kind of harassing the
clans and giving them incorrect
directions and roughing him up and then
what what kind of probably turned the
whole thing a little rougher was the
Notre Dame students decided that a set
of these Klan robes would make the ideal
trophy of the day they can manage to set
bring a Klansman from his robes this
picture you see here is not a Klansman
it's a Notre Dame sophomore named
William phooey who who managed to get
his hands on a set of robes he's posing
in front of sophomore hall there and you
can read it in the book but one of the
things I found out in researching the
book was that I was friends with this
guy's grandson when I was at number game
so it was kind of a coincidence after
the the robes the only phase of the riot
run its course the thing to keep in mind
with the Klansmen is that they were
completely bewildered by this for such
and everywhere the clans went had gone
in Indiana they've been welcomed with
open arms and they presented themselves
as this patriotic organization and they
were just the wilderness this thing that
they were a part of so they were caught
completely off guard by the reception
they got they started to coalesce at the
plan headquarters at the corner of
michigan wayne just looking for a safe
place to go and so the notre dame
students went there to that building in
the third floor window had a fiery cross
it was a key was fiery it was made out
of red electric light bulbs in the
third-floor window and as luck would
have it there was a grocery on the first
floor and another name students
confiscated the potatoes that were in a
barrel out front and started throwing
them at the window trying to extinguish
that electric fiery cross now if you
were part of the leadership of Notre
Dame at that point and you were worried
about the image of these young Irish
Catholic men in the community this
picture of a potato hurling mob was
about the worst possible image that you
could happen so that the public
relations disaster for Notre Dame was
well under way they extinguished the
cross and then they got enough
conference they decided to try and take
the building and about a hundred Notre
Dame students I gathered their courage
and ran up the stairs where they were
met by a pistol wielding a Baptist
minister at the top of the steps and
another name students for the only time
all day were treated I think it's a it
shows you that the potential for real
violence was was there all day long with
that pistol in fact one of the many
arrests that day was a Klansman was
arrested with a small cannon on Main
Street earlier the day so there was a
potential for real violence but at this
point the Notre Dame students had
completely won the day they ruled the
streets pwease were non-existent and the
Klansmen were on the run and whole
up in their building and furious for the
most part in shocked soon after begin a
torrential downpour that ruined what had
been the nicest day so far the spring
and the Notre Dame students were treated
to campus and the visiting Klansmen went
back to their cars and the train
platforms I'm sure saying that it had
been the absolute worst Klan rally ever
DC Stephenson was able to save face by
saying that he canceled the parade
because of the rain and not because of
the Notre Dame mom the day after was
Sunday and both sides rested the PR
backlash and all the paper was solidly
against the Notre Dame students who were
really seeing as the aggressors in this
case Walsh as always chose to ignore it
which allowed the clan to really take
the high ground in the PR battle and the
Klansmen and the police force were both
stinging from what has happened and as a
response the sheriff deputized 30
Klansmen on Sunday and they began to
kind of plan their ambush for the next
day on the next day which was Monday
they set their trap that clandon South
Bend had its regularly scheduled meeting
on Monday night and the Klansmen after
the meeting they lined both sides of the
street and they made a phone call on
campus me so we've got one of your boys
in town and we're beating them up and
the Notre Dame students who ever had
missed all the fun on Saturday wasn't
about to miss it on Monday and as a
group they ran into campus and the guys
I talked over there said they were
pretty sure that nobody remained on
campus so they ran into town where the
Klansmen and the Sheriff's Department
was waiting for him the Klan had revenge
on their minds and the law enforcement
wanted to show that they in fact were in
charge and the Notre Dame students took
an awful awful beating at one point they
were treated at a courthouse there were
reports of shots fired and the Chief of
Police Florence Lane had been a Notre
Dame student he called Matthew Walsh and
said you got to come down here you got
to come down here and get these boys
back so loss went into town and he found
a large group of the Notre Dame students
on the courthouse lawn where they were
kind of catching their breath and
deciding what to do next and whilst
applying to top a cannon in front of the
civil war monument
and gave an impromptu speech and very
dramatically call for the students to
return to campus and they did and that
was more or less the end of the riots
immediately after DC Stephenson
published his account of the rides in
book form called what really happened in
South Bend where he described Notre Dame
students turning over baby carriages and
trampling on the American flag and walsh
continued to studied obliviousness
towards the clan and the clan the clan
immediately after the rights was still
very much on an upswing walls did have
to swallow his pride though he knew that
this had already happened two days and
if it happened again something really
serious could happen so he swallowed his
pride and he asked the man on campus who
had the most proven ability to motivate
the young men and Notre Dame it was new
Rockne and he called an all-hands
meeting in Washington hall and had Knute
Rockne give them a speech where he said
kind of in locker-room pep talk fashion
that they were all members of the Notre
Dame team and that father Wallace was
their quarterback and that they had to
follow his signals and then and then he
made him take notes saying that they
would riot no more so that was the end
of the right and like I said in the
immediate aftermath it looked like while
one day the rights a gun to Notre Dame
and one day had gone to the clan the
clan in Indiana was still very much on
an upswing after the riot the Klansmen
at Jackson was elected governor in
November the following November but the
writing was on the wall Stevenson met
Matt Oberholtzer who was a state
employee a Ted Jackson inauguration and
within months he and kidnapped her a
raped her for three days and and
returned her to her home where she
eventually died the prosecution argued
that she actually died from the bite
wounds that Stevenson a given her that
were so severe as Stevenson had the
trial moved to noblesville you all know
where that is in Hamilton County it was
a great victory to get this venue moved
Hamilton County was the second strongest
clan county in the state but the
clansmen jury assuming they were
Klansmen or potential Klansmen
didn't like what they heard about
Stephenson and they convicted him but
Stephenson he still had reason to be
smug his governor are the governor was
good friend and he had every reason to
believe that he would be pardoned but he
wasn't and in fact Stephenson ended up
doing the longest sentence in Indiana
history for second-degree murder this is
this is innocent here on the courthouse
steps during the trial so if he doesn't
look too worried the following year
Notre Dame when its first national
championship this is a famous photograph
that accompany the famous piece of
sports writing by a sportswriter named
Grantland rice where he wrote about
against the blue grey October Sky and
the four horsemen buting army it's been
described as the most famous lead in the
history of sports writing this
photograph was taken by a Notre Dame
student to capitalize on this story and
he printed off a thousands of copies at
his own expense and sold them for a
dollar apiece and quit school does he
decide enough money after that Walsh
Walsh they had mandatory six-year terms
for presidents at that time the minute
Walsh left the office Rockne was able to
get his new stadium built and he played
in it for one year he won another
national championship and then that
winter he was flying in one of the early
early commercial flights in this country
to Los Angeles to film a movie about a
football coach and outside of bizarre
kansas the plain iced up and crashed and
Rockne died after playing only one
season in his stadium the stadium today
they added a ring of about 20,000 seats
you can see
here the mark you'll video that that's
six-year term that Walt served is gone
and I wrote in the book that Notre Dame
has only had two presidents in the last
50 years but among muy up and retired on
me when i wrote that so that's not true
anymore but there he is Malloy his
father was Irish and since walls every
president of Notre Dame has either been
Irish or had an irish-born parent which
I'm sure father sworn rolls over in his
grave every time and that's PowerPoint
does anybody have any questions I'm
supposed to remind you to step up to the
microphone anyone
two door neighbor at that time now not
for a long long time not till nineteen
seventy-two and when cone at in 1972 and
they just had their they had the 30th
anniversary that not two on the
publisher of my first book notre dame
game they had been in that first
graduating class of women a notre dame
I've enjoyed reading the book immensely
and I think if you would comment
generally on your experiences in
researching this book and more
specifically on the research that
allowed you to extrapolate on the
conversations and interactions of the
principles in the book that's a really
good question i did i was fortunate that
i had two witnesses I had a guy named hi
Proust and a guy named George Sawyer who
had been at the riot so I had I was able
to interview those two gentlemen on
ranks and that helped me a lot the in
some cases men that had been the
right-handed the story down to their to
their kids with with the conversations
of walsh and stevenson it was easier
because they had such a track record of
correspondents and speeches and was
relatively easy to extrapolate you know
what what they might have said in in in
the immediate aftermath of the riot when
notre dame law enforcement was blaming
the students for everything walsh
actually had the priesthood have been
involved with the conversations with the
police front right a transcript of the
conversations that had taken place so a
few cases i actually had you know
transcripts almost like a script but
another cases I'd extrapolated from
speeches and letters and correspondence
another good question I one of the thing
that's interesting is he talking about
you know why was the clan so strong the
clan did grow as a response to these
massive waves as emigrate of immigration
but Indiana was virtually untouched in
Ohio and Illinois on each side of indy
and I had much higher percentage of
immigrants than Indiana did Indiana by
any measure was one of the most
homogenous states in the country if you
look at the census data but the
exception of that were the northern
counties steel country and South Bend
where these factories actively recruited
immigrants from Eastern Europe so I
think the Catholic the immigrant
population in 1924 in Indiana's the
whole is about 5% Lake County in Indiana
which is the you know the northwest
corner where Gary is had the highest
percentage I can't wear the exact number
but it was in the 20s and in the second
highest percentage Catholic immigrants
was st. Joe County which is where Notre
Dame was
I can't that's a great question but I do
not know the the papers in Indiana by
and large were pro clan the exceptions
were the indianapolis star and the south
bend tribune most papers if you read
local paper accounts of these Klan
rallies than they happen if you just
read the account you think you were
reading about a 4-h fair or a fourth of
July rally I mean the papers buying
large thought is a very benign thing the
exceptions of that were the Indianapolis
papers and the South Bend papers but who
they endorsed I could speculate that
they endorsed his opponent but I don't
know
offers
that I think I think what you're asking
is really the big historical question
here is that why did the clan succeed so
much more in Indiana than anywhere else
and any any demographic you can point to
an Indiana you can find in other states
you can find an Ohio or Illinois so the
question remains why did this take off
like it did in Indiana and there are a
lot of kind of weird theories about that
one is that Indiana unlike most
Midwestern states was settled from south
to north rather than from East OS so we
had this southern racist DNA that made
the clan successful in Indiana that's
one of the theories you hear there's
also theories about the traumatic
urbanization of Indiana
industrialization I drove this reaction
but I I mean what I think after after
kind of living with this story for three
years I think that it was more
successful in Indiana than anywhere else
because they had the best salesman in DC
Stephenson I think that that that's why
Stephenson ran the clan like a
professional sales organization and his
efforts showed
it was a the clan was different things
to different people in the South the
clan was was very much still a racist
organization in Indiana there where the
black population was so small there was
no that wouldn't that wouldn't be good
marketing for Stephenson so his main
target and Indiana were Catholics and a
lot of times in Stevenson's marketing
literature and his pitch it was not
presented that negatively he didn't say
I'm anti-catholic what he said was I'm a
hundred percent pure American and if you
read between the lines of those speeches
what that means is when you're pure
American means you're not Catholic
because how can you be how can you be a
hundred percent american when you take
this this oath or have this loyalty to
this foreign ruler ie the Pope I mean
that's always been a plank of
anti-catholicism in America and the Klan
kind of made it their own they said that
you can't against not possible that a
Catholic of the higher percent patriotic
by virtue of their religion so in
Indiana but it was mostly presented as
you know not a negative what is a
positive your 100% patriotic American
makes you a good Klansmen
it in what here's what happened
Stephenson had a lot to do with bringing
the clan down directly because
Stephenson went to prison for the murder
of Matt Oberholtzer he fully expected
his friend at Jackson the to pardon him
he owed it to him but it didn't happen
well Stevenson had very very good
survival skills and what he had done was
he had scrolled away incriminating
documents and safety deposit boxes
across the state including one from the
mayor of Indianapolis John Duval where
it literally said in black and white I
will make no appointments for any jobs
without the approval of DC Stephenson
sign John Duval and there were there
were hundreds of documents like that
across the debate and when Stevenson saw
that his friends had all deserted him
and we're just going to let him rot in
prison he started engineering the
release of these documents to the
newspapers so the newspapers published
them but Stephenson released them and he
was going to use going to punish those
people that didn't stand by him
well the riot got a lot of national
press and most of it was almost entirely
unfavorable towards Notre Dame the
allowed newspapers found this image of
the potato throwing Irish mob
irresistible and printed account of that
and Stephenson was a very accomplished
PR man and he engineered the press and
also decided just to ignore the whole
thing and not take him on so it really
allowed the clan to kind of control the
way that the thing was covered but it
did get it did get national coverage
[Music]
well nobody thought that the Notre Dame
students had done a good thing I think
you can say that except for maybe some
of the Notre Dame students but you know
the some papers were definitely more
anti clan than others but the best one
was there was a group founded in
response to the clan called the American
unity League by a kind of fanatical
Irishman in chicago named Pat O'Donnell
who was called almost by everyone mad
Pat O'Donnell and his favorite thing to
do was to break into clan offices steal
their membership rolls and publish the
names and he was the firt he was kind of
the gadfly he was the first guy to
really say you can't if you the theory
that you can ignore this and it's going
to go away is not going to work in
Indiana a secretary of state to Klansmen
the governors of Klansmen and he was the
first to say this and everybody thought
he was crazy anyone actually he was
crazy but it turns out he was right too
and he the Stevenson and kind of a
typically clever Stevenson move to
combat Oh Donald because he was having
an effect people were afraid to join the
clan they from afraid they'd be outed in
this paper it was called the paper was
called tolerance and what Stephenson did
was he started planning the names of the
rich and famous on membership rolls and
letting O'Donnell steel and
which is rush headlong into publishing
this and then one of the names was
william wrigley in Chicago in wrigley
promptly sue diamond and Stevens was
able to [ __ ] the organization by
doing that because O'Donnell never he
wasn't big on fact-checking you would
just publish these roles but she was
really one of the first and he had a
long communication with Notre Dame about
the problem and had friends at Notre
Dame but then he published a list of
Notre Dame faculties that he said were
in the clan and at that point the
president Notre Dame at that time was a
guy he was an ex-president but his name
was Cavanaugh and he he engineered the
banishment of O'Donnell because he
thought O'Donnell had embarrassed the
University and he thought that was
unforgivable and he ran him out of town
so it wasn't actually the clan that ran
O'Donnell adil southbend it was Notre
Dame yes ma'am
I'm sorry well the trial of DC Stevens
has got enormous press coverage it was
it was the longest trial the most
expensive trial at the time in the
history of Indiana what in fact I when I
went to the state library to research
one of the one of the big there's a lot
of conspiracy theories about Stevenson's
conviction one of them is that the
transcript is never the transcript is
lost the transcript doesn't exist and
when I went to the State Library to talk
to them about they said they only the
only trial they get asked about more
than DC Stephenson is to Mike Tyson
trial so I think it was kind of on par
you know in terms of the kind of
publicity of God and plus the nature of
the crime was just so horrific that it
just attracted that kind of media so
that got a lot of attention the rise of
the clan would didn't get as much
national press it happened so fast and
there wasn't a lot of time for analysis
and most people that saw it they bought
into the clan line that the Klan was
just about patriotism and being an
American and was it was a
non-threatening movement to a lot of
people yes sir
it's the story is not told and it was
virtually unknown and people ask me all
the time you know why doesn't notre dame
brag about this well at notre dame is a
long stubborn institutional memory when
george gip was converted to catholicism
on his deathbed he was delirious and
hours away from death and he supposedly
woke up and was lucid enough to request
that he be converted to Catholicism
which his devoutly Baptist family was
absolutely horrified by and they refused
to allow any Notre Dame representative
his funeral and they said you can never
put a monument to George Gipp on your
campus that was in nineteen twenty
there's still no monuments of George
Gipp on campus so Notre Dame doesn't
like to remember these things they I
think you know that the riot the way
Notre Dame style was that this was the
worst incident ever in the history of
South Bend Notre Dame relations and
these they see no need to memorialize it
and I think beside it beyond that they
it recalls this very painful chapter for
Notre Dame for Catholics in general when
they were thus feared and hated minority
and they see no you know they didn't
have a great urge to relive that but
Walsh for his part he never punished a
single student even though he dish ood
that written order commanding them all
to stay on campus he never punished a
single student for involvement in the
riot
yes ma'am saralyn Buffett he was right
see I don't think anybody knew Stevenson
was an opportunities from way back he
was he worked for the socialist
candidate for governor in Oklahoma when
he first got to evansville before the
Klan came line he ran for Congress as a
Democrat and then with the rise of the
clan he wanted to associate the clan
with the dominant political party in the
state which was Republican at Jackson
was a Republican so Stephenson didn't
have a great loyalty doll those but no
nobody ever you know the swift boat
veterans for truth never published an ad
saying that the Stephenson was a
socialist so this man live in indiana
the clams are certainly an entire black
oh absolutely absolutely I have a couple
questions in one
about looking at Notre Dame students I
and the love administration to
Catholicism in terms of sure well a
couple of a couple of things it was
almost entirely a Midwestern school
almost all the students came from
Illinois Ohio or Indiana they were about
75% Catholic Notre Dame has never
required its students to all be Catholic
in fact for most of its history that
would have been unthinkable because the
school depended on the tuition dollars
of locals so much who were not Catholic
by and large so an interesting statistic
that I found in this is that Notre Dame
is actually more it was actually more
diverse in 1924 than it is today a
higher percentage of students are
Catholic today than they were in 1924
which I thought was interesting the
school admitted more or less anybody
that could pay tuition it was not a
demanding you know in terms of
admissions and tuition was a hundred
dollars a year which at that time
average income was twelve hundred
dollars a year for the average American
man so you could send your son to Notre
Dame for about one month's pay which
cannot be said today hi Allah thought so
but it was it was a very Catholic school
mass tense was required for Catholic
students theology was required and
almost everybody in the administration
were priests and a good number of the
professors were priests as well the
university saw this as a great way to
kind of it served a couple of purpose
format they went to the trouble of
getting a priest at PhD like Matty
Wolf's then they had a full professor
that they didn't have to pay a priest
and and also it the civilian
quote-unquote civilian professors had
you know a troubling habit of
questioning the authority of the of the
administration sometimes which they
didn't have to worry about that with
priests so they like doing that but the
school was you know it was a religious
school then and now that answer your
question
oh well that's a really good question I
you know I had heard as it as a student
of history I mean I've always thought
that I've always felt that like a lot of
history the Midwest is is neglected
somewhat you know and and there's a lot
of amazing historical things that have
had from the Midwest I think don't get
the attention they deserve I had heard
about the riot when I was a notre dame
but like most students in her name i
think i'd heard a lot of really crazy
versions of it where like george gip was
at the front of the mom and he'd been
dead for four years when i when i
started when i started looking into it I
I guess the thing that really grabbed me
was that you had these you had these two
institutions but you these two people
you had father Matthew also war hero who
left the vice president at university to
fight in the war and he had to listen to
these accusations that he couldn't be a
hundred percent american because he was
catholic and then he had DC Stephenson
this kind of crazed genius who somehow
built the clan up to this point in three
years and then you know within a year
was convicted of this monstrous crime
and I his thought this isn't this is a
decision if it was fiction you wouldn't
believe it so I decided to write about
it would have been yes sir that's a
great point and that was what the
defense argued match over halter when
she was kidnapped Stephenson held her
for three days and at one point and the
accounts of this were widely diverged
but everyone this was a green upon by
everybody she attempted suicide while
she was with Stevenson she bought
mercury by chloride pills at a drugstore
somehow and when it snuck into the
bathroom and took as many as she could
and trying to kill herself the defense
argued that that's what it killed her
and it seems pretty reasonable she was
trying to kill herself and she died but
the prosecution argued that had nothing
to do with this it was actually the the
infections from the bite wounds of
Stevenson that had killed her and the
prosecution won the case but it's
definitely very arguable and there was a
lot of like I said there's a lot of
conspiracy theory Stevenson had acquired
so many political enemies that he was
one of those guys where it's easy to
construct these conspiracies that he was
that he was somehow convicted wrongly
but I show in the book that Stevenson
had a long history of abusing women in
his life so I don't think that he was
framed like he said but there are like I
said there are some unusual things that
kind of fueled the conspiracy theory
fire one the transcript has disappeared
banjul rollers deathbed account of this
was was notarized by in front of her and
her lawyer on trial they couldn't
remember who the notary was and never
found the notary but it notarized this
and Stephenson ended up serving the
longest sentence of Indiana history for
second-degree murder and a lot of people
thought he was just locked away so he
couldn't release any more damaging
secrets about his friends that had been
Klansmen but I think when you look at
Stevenson's record you know it's pretty
clear that the guy was a monster with
lemon in absolute
incredible drinker too which fueled all
this yes sir it was granted a clemency
on Christmas for Christmas in 1956
violated his parole and was put back in
and then he got back out in the 60s and
he went to Seymour Indiana and got back
in the newspaper business and then he
married a woman he had a bad habit of
marrying women without divorcing the
last woman he'd been married so but he
went from seymour to tennessee where he
married another woman and lived with her
kind of true his retirement and I think
in 63 somewhere around there he was
carrying a bag of groceries from his car
to the house and drop dead of a heart
attack a reporter from the Louisville
courier-journal which is where my mother
worked went to interview his widow after
he died and she was quite shocked to
hear about the clan she seemed so they
never mentioned it to her the whole
story of the clan yes sir
yeah I have no record of that I don't
know I don't know if it got that fire or
not I know that when you one of the
complicated weird things you have to
learn when you study church history is
this weird relationship that exists
between and archdiocese and the orders
that operate kind of semi independently
within the archdiocese so I'm sure that
the archdiocese to saw this is more
trouble caused by Notre Dame for them
yes man wondering about the bulletin
that was posted all over campus saying
don't go right you think that way I mean
that was almost like anything a red
sweater a pin and the students I talking
do you think he was sincere in them I
think he was very sincere and I trying
to make that point in a book like I
agree with you i mean if i had read that
as another name student I would have
been gone before I before I finished
reading it but Walsh if you read about
hit how he was he would have obeyed that
he would have obeyed that order he was
always the good boy and he would have
listened to that and I think that's why
he thought it would work but what's more
is that it was impossible to command the
Notre Dame students to stand kids
because so many of them lived in town
that was a big part of the problem Notre
Dame had grown so rapidly they couldn't
accommodate all the students in town so
it was meaningless to say staying on
campus so many of them couldn't weren't
there to begin with but yeah it
definitely you know I I interviewed like
i said this George swear it was 98 years
old when I interviewed him and I asked
him I said you know you guys wrong dude
castle boys been the Catholic school all
your life and now you have this order
from a priest and the president
University commanding you to stay on
campus plus all the law enforcement
wanted you to stay on campus I said it
must have taken a lot of anger you guys
to violate all that and run into town he
said no that really
he says we were ready to go yes ma'am he
never made an official statement the
closest he did was the meeting he called
was Knute Rockne in his private letters
he consistently downplayed he called it
the Klan happenings and said that the
thinking people of South been are all
with us and his you know his theory
throughout all this again ignored the
yahoos and eventually they'll go away
and tried to maintain that that
philosophy throughout so no he never
issues like a press release meanwhile
Stevenson was issuing press releases 123
trying to get the story out about they
overturn baby carriages and stomping on
the American flag yes ma'am well I don't
you know I don't know about that I don't
know if a child the Klansmen would have
sent his kid to Notre Dame but the the
people that I talk to that were there
said that the campus was empty
especially on the second day because by
then everybody had heard how fun it was
on Saturday and they weren't they
weren't about to be left out a second
time and that's exactly what the Klan
was counting on anyone
yes sir I don't excuse it live but a lot
of cold butter that's correct and so did
man yeah I think his father I believe it
had a more liberal education Gary too
many conflicts between boner no I I know
that magical halters parents were
thrilled when she began dating him
because he was seen as such a powerful
you know influential figure that it
seemed like a really good thing he was
in irvington like you said the only
conflict I think he ever had with his
neighbors that I read about was that he
tore down his home and built up an exact
replica of the clan national
headquarters in Atlanta and it's placed
called clan crest and built that in
erdington and I know that the
construction project irritated some of
the neighbors but no i don't i don't
know of any you know conflict with
butler yes sir
Jost and I reservation stop declaratory
ever
it it was and the tensions in the
building for a long time in the right
was a real watershed event and the
aftermath on the riot Walsh took all of
rockne's stadium fund and built new
dormitories with it to bring the
students back to campus he built three
dorms all paid cash for all three of
them right on the south end of campus
today Howard more seeing lions and by
the end of the lawless presidency
something in the high 90s percent of
students were living on campus and
eating all their meals on campus and it
will also regarded this as one of the
great achievements of his presidency
that he brought the students back to
campus and after that Walt absolutely
detested the South Bend chief of police
warrant slain for what he regarded as a
betrayal when blaine blamed the students
who Notre Dame and he he it's one of the
only letters you'll get with wall sorts
it's obviously emotional or he talks
about the nauseating police chief and
how he can't stand to be in the room
with him and it's really the only time
you ever hear walls use language like
that is when he's talking about the
chief please but that that distrust
between Notre Dame and the civic
authorities of South Bend I think has
lasted clear through till today
is that right that's interesting well
they on that first day of Rights one of
the one of the great trophies of the
Notre Dame in which they managed to
steal this clan banner and they they ran
it up the central flagpole on campus who
were dancing around at chanting
obscenities and apparently it was a it
was just absolutely the horrifying into
a horrifying day for the administration
of Notre Dame I think you know that
there were in the 20s there were
somewhere around one out of three white
men were in the clan but you know it's
hard to find somebody that wants to talk
about it it was in the clan okay okay